it's morning rush hour on the board of a
lockdown district
and it's chaos
the police checkpoint stops one in every
10 or 15 cars
but that's all they're expecting people
to self-police it's a big ask
if this is a lockdown it's not going to
work
[Music]
inside the lockdown areas life seems
well pretty normal the shops are open
the streets are busy
compulsory face masks obediently worn by
everyone
are the only giveaway it's almost
lunchtime and around the corner the
local food bank is starting to get busy
the pandemic has left francesco and
carmel unemployed
and desperate he's been fired twice from
his job in a restaurant
and now the proud waiter is forced to
beg for free food
okay
we want people to help us to give us a
future where we value
ourselves because the way we are living
has no future
this isn't a life even if you wanted it
to be be honest i'm hoping for help from
my friends to find work
soon because i'm of a working age and
can work
i'm hoping for an opportunity because
all i want is a chance to keep going
ahead
just like the rest of the world
madrid's hospitals are filling up but
still coping
it's the rising death toll here that is
of most concern
a senior doctor who is on the front line
of the second wave
had this plea for the people of britain
what we have to do is just
during a few weeks this is not you know
forever
then we have to to wear the mask and you
know and we no no
this is just for a few weeks and doing
that you know
this short time we could control the
pandemic if not
we are going to pay this you know very
very very very very very closely
army tents have been put up in hospital
grounds and madrid's regional government
has asked the military for help
if you want to know where britain could
be headed
spain is a good guide the days ahead
are going to be tough for everyone alice
to bundle sky news
madrid